Lincoln Reilly was on Dan Patrick show
today and had this to say about Charlie
cash Lily's report on it if I'm Network
yesterday that he's heard from those in
the know from the interview rooms at the
combine that Kyler Mari had a dreadful
dreadful time of it in the interview
room this was his head coach Lincoln
Riley on DP show earlier on Wednesday
it's that time of year you know um
people are gonna say different things I
just hate that people go out make these
comments and you know you've never even
talked to people that have actually
coach this kid probably smokescreen no
another this drive still works and all
the different back-and-forth but Connor
was a tremendous leader for us a
tremendous leader all he cares about
winning I think our team took on that
personality without a doubt and then as
far as processes offense I mean he just
had you know greatest single season and
the history college football so I think
he could process just fraud
alright longtime general manager from
the Washington Redskins Super Bowl
winning general manager and the man who
helped get the Texans off the ground and
also a compadre of menthe at the NFL
Network Charlie casually here on the
show how are you Charlie
hey good to be with you what'd you think
of Lincoln Reilly's comments Charlie
well what else you gonna say let's start
there okay hey I'm telling my reporters
from three teams okay or more it's more
than two of what their impression was in
a 15-minute interview okay that's that's
what I repeated okay and I obviously I'm
not going to reveal the team's nor am I
going to reveal some specific things
that were said but I'm giving you the
summary of the overview of it now I've
never been guys who failed the interview
room and go on and had successful
careers just telling you that's what he
did in that situation on Friday and I'm
going to plug my segments up Friday up
to the minute one o'clock two o'clock
Eastern this is pre-planned because work
was already done before I went on
television yesterday everybody says well
this guy's got to be in a certain office
well what's that I'm going to show you
the certain offense that he can be in to
be successful on tape this guy was a
phenomenal player there's
question about that no one denies that
the interview didn't go well we'll find
out you know at the end of the day rich
is going to be system has to match what
he can do and I can show that that can
be done and it's done in the NFL this
guy's work ethic intelligence I
shouldn't say tell us his study habits
that's what's going to be a question
what was it asked Riley was compared to
Baker Mayfield Baker Mayfield way ahead
of this guy when he would have said that
on the air I doubt it well what do you
mean by that Baker Mayfield way ahead of
this guy charlie just in the area of the
leadership and the study habits and the
work habits and let's just say grasping
concepts put into a test situation may
feel Russell Wilson and mahomes way
ahead of this guy and those guys have
all proven in the NFL that they can
adapt their game to the NFL structure as
far as work habits studying everything
you know in college it's it's more of a
reactive type thing that it doesn't
scratch the service many times with the
spread office and what they're gonna
have to do in the NFL but there is a way
to adapt his skillset to be successful
well Charlie I mean not to you know have
you reveal your sources as you already
said you won't and I don't blame you and
what about the idea that these teams are
smoke screening in a way to try and well
let me favor
I mean let me say sorry to cut you off
accord these three these three people
were not smoke screening me that's all I
can tell you so there's a mean but you
know that there are people who have
agendas to try and maybe make sure that
he doesn't show up in their division or
maybe show make sure he doesn't show up
in their conference or try and knock him
down because they don't like the agent
or try and knock him down for various
reasons I mean you I don't think I'm
telling he tells out of school or
accusing your your colleagues or sources
for doing that but you are saying this
isn't unvarnished on I guess non-agenda
opinion from people who told you about
calamari
absolutely no question in my mind zero
question so how is it possible though
that he doesn't have the leadership
skills or didn't portray them they're
talking about
domani guy had a bad interview clearly
rich this guy was not trained for an
interview
it's obvious based on the comments made
to me I've trained players for coming
I've trained I trained over a hundred
players a year for interviews but
combine just no way this guy was trained
okay so now you're talking about a guy
who's not trained in the interview and
says some things that are absolutely off
the wall okay you'd never say them if
you were trained now that all comes out
when you go visit then you spend a day
with this guy okay what I would do it
this guy I'd say okay okay Luis so now
let's go three or twelve fourteen games
let's start let's go and then let's go
through every one every play we're going
we're thinking about taking in the top
ten on the first round let's go do that
let's see how it goes that's going to be
more of a chance than a 15-minute
interview all I'm saying is this is what
I said it's what they would say it was a
15-minute interview charlie casually of
NFL Network here in the Honda inside a
report you say scheme and player can fit
in regardless of poorly interviewing
this can wind up as a successful
marriage in the NFL is Arizona one of
those teams Charlie
well Arizona to me is the obvious one
and and you know as we reported
yesterday and Steve wife's back it up
they have shot this guy now the way I
look at Arizona's let's start in the
interview process rich I talked to
somebody who was interviewed and they
made it clear Rosen was their
quarterback this coach obviously didn't
get the job because I didn't talk to
Kingsbury but this coach had a lot of
questions and running warts on Rosen
which he had in college we've all talked
about last year it's nothing new so he
was all concerned about Evan as a
quarterback so now you hire Kingsbury
who's on record as saying he loves
murray well that's fine I there's
nothing wrong with that he loved him in
high school okay there's nothing wrong
with that
to me if you're going to go hire an
outlier like Kingsbury who might be a
brilliant coach I give him his
quarterback given my rap said that
already
on Twitter just to plug Twitter here but
said that a couple weeks ago what I
would think about hard is this rich if
I'm the general manager and I was sold
on Rosa now that's a big if I was sold
on him not I just had to take him
because yet Darnell was going to me
feels gone I didn't want Alan I'm sold
on that guy
I'll draft Kingsbury I'm keeping Rosen
better have two than one now if I'm both
I took Rosen on default okay then I then
I'd have to go you know I try to trade
him now it was if you get a third form a
third is only a thirty percent success
rate shoot I might keep the guy so all
right so let me walk through let me walk
through this one by one here so you're
when I'm when I mention Arizona and
you're like they're shopping the guy who
obviously mean Rosen and you said Steve
watch back that up I was told that he
was that Rosen was told he's the man
he's the guy I guess as a general
manager in this league both things can
be possible you tell the the team that
hey we're good and then still go shop
him that's feasible that can be done
well I never did that by the way okay I
was if I told the player he was there
that was it
okay there were all of us a degree that
was it that's where we're going to tell
him I wouldn't go back on it sometimes
people change their minds I thought it
was interesting that they qualified the
statement he's our quarterback for now I
mean he's our quarterback I'm not going
to say he's a quarterback for now now me
so shopping him now I mean doesn't that
put you in a box
you got a draft calimary you see what
I'm saying like it's it's there's still
50 days to the draft here I mean what
are the odds that this is actually a
decision that Arizona has made and that
one of the interviews that maybe
Calamari aced was Arizona's and go ahead
and let's see what Rosen's out there the
for the phone's ringing for rosin
because you had you did put it out there
that he was our quarterback right now
that you for short it in that respect
walk me through how our Steve crime
might be mapping this 50-day
well first of all if you're going to
shop a guy that sit
I wouldn't shop a guy unless I had a
plan to replace him okay so the plan to
replace them would be Kingsbury so if
I'm sorry Murray then then the argue
then you can make the argument a we a
we're not excited about Rosen after one
year or two we don't we don't want the
quarterback controversy and I get that
one now I get that one because that can
be disruptive so he's our Kings burgers
excuse me
Murray's our man we're going with them
we got to move this guy out of here and
and that but from the outside in that
seems like that's what they're doing do
I know they're doing that no I know I
know they've shot them and I know the
guy is saying he's quarterback for now
which tells me that there's a maybe to
trade him well so I mean we've both been
in a long time if you get up there and
say he's our man that's one thing he's
our man for now that's that's another
thing one more on this subject with you
Charlie is there any example you can
give from your sourcing on how poorly
the interview went just a little bit
more meat on the bones here just what
what does that mean I mean give me what
you think you cannot yeah no not to me I
got to say generic and that's it and
people will choose to believe what I say
or not choose to believe what I say
based on you know whether what they
think of my credibility so which is fine
I don't care about that I I know I know
with these people or I know they trust
him I trust what they say trust their
opinion time will tell as other
interviews came out now I was led to
believe and I never said this by a
baseball person that his interview would
not go good so he I think he knew
something kid I know that from a
baseball executive mmm is that okay
baseball person alright and so let me
let me try it it this way then if you
don't mind me
Charlie cassoulet here on the Rich Eisen
show in the Honda inside a report no III
know hey I know how to give the same
answer no no no I know that let me try
listen I know this is not your first
rodeo Charlie casually I understand that
you said it was the one of the worst
evaluations you've ever heard for a
quarterback correct that's what you said
okay so give me give me a previously
worst evaluation on a quarterback that
you've heard before yeah I won't do that
either no I won't put out a name of
somebody that I've never used at the
time no okay very good
who's the best player available in the
draft then in your estimation well I had
Bosa and I don't know that I would
change it there so none of those new
defensive linemen up there pretty good
by I like boasts of better than
everybody I know he didn't run quite as
fast as I had hoped personally his drill
work was not at the top of the chart
rashon Gary here your fellow for
Michigan had better drill work but I
just thought on the tape he's the best
defensive lineman I thought he was
explosive off the edge I thought he had
a great inside move I thought he played
with leverage against the run and played
it well too so I'm still gonna put him
there wise you know obviously the
combine and the drills are just one
piece of the puzzle and that's why you
know I was kind of taking it back to
here well that Haskins didn't grab the
stage like he should have with Murray
not working out at all what's what is
the word on Haskins with the Giants
sitting there at 6:00 and then obviously
if Murray did fail the interview to the
point that he did that that might affect
some way his draft status what do you
what do you have on Haskins Charlie and
what you're hearing about my guess on
Murray is this let me start there are
certain teams that wouldn't take them
because of the size and they're in a
system there are certain teams if
they're on the fence they're going to
spend a lot more time trying to decide
this and there are other teams it made
no difference to them I'll guarantee
none whatsoever okay on Haskins a a good
interview on the board sharp guy no
question about that I think he's got a
big upside I think that his throwing was
and you got to be careful if thrown to
receivers they never practice so I
really don't spend much time on it I
looked at a little bit more this year I
watch the games
I thought his
well he was arcing it more and I said
where the hell that come from because
that one to Sue's the language I didn't
see that in the tape that maybe somebody
trying to teach him something about
getting the ball out quick and throwing
it up and at that it doesn't look right
when you watch them do it at the combine
so I can't see the Giants taking a 5
foot 10 quarterback in the Meadowlands
that that's just a gut falls everybody
seems to think he'll be in Jacksonville
make sense dee Phillip o is the
quarterback coach and they can get it
and they're a team that feels that they
can win now
so unless Tampa and I think Tampa I take
this guy over the guy they got in Tampa
now I think he's got a clear shot to the
Giants and I think the Giants take them
that's my gut so you know I take the guy
big strong-armed guy and beat upside so
what you think Haskins to the Giants is
the best is the best guess right here so
let me let me ask you this finally
Charlie so rank it for me here you're a
quarterback needy franchise and and I
understand that there's realities in the
free-agent front but then there's also
realities on how far you can trade up or
whatever rank it for me
Haskins Mauri free agent quarterback how
would you go to try and fill that
quarterback need if you have to right
here right now over the next 50 days I
would take Haskins over any free agent
meaning Falls or Bridgewater are really
the two guys and I would take them over
Murray I think fits every system Murray
can win in a certain system but
everybody's going to be on board on that
and I do worry about the body type I
mean he weighed 207 but I don't know
that he played at 207 he looks like
small he that takes some hits now and
you got to survive those hits so then
maybe he can maybe he can and then I
would have Jones I would take of Duke
over Falls and I like Bridgewater nobody
nobody wants to talk about Bridgewater
but I know there's a little bit of a I
would say uncertainty there with him but
Bridgewater might be the sleeper in this
whole thing when it's over sis I've done
Charlie not appreciate the time really
do
maybe next week if you're around in Los
Angeles for the free agent we'll have
you here in person to hit it again chop
it up thanks for the call yeah I'd love
to do it thanks charlie you got it and
by the way it's at at charlie casually
on twitter what else do I need to
promote Charlie what else do I got to
get out there on the Charlie casually
get up laughing up-to-the-minute Friday
1:00 o'clock to 2 o'clock will show you
how Murray can win in the NFL oh you oh
okay so you're gonna be fair and
balanced is what you're saying
Bob absolutely this is gonna be me
looking at his tape and look at an NFL
tape and showing you how this guy can
win in the NFL okay question about it
that's mine we got we got the answer
Friday okay cuz you're hearing people
saying you're throwing this stuff out
there that you're hearing from the
combine unsubstantiated on source you're
just trying to kill the kid well let me
say this Watergate was unsubstantiated -
now the source in Watergate never came
out in it who's your deep throat charlie
casually who's the deep throat hey I
live in Washington I I know about done
things like this so hey I'm dying I'm
dying with my sources that's it okay
Charlie thanks for thanks to the call
we'll chat soon it's Charlie castling
the one moment the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience